إنه أسود للغاية يبدو وكأنه خطأ ،
قد تبدو كل هذه الأشياء سوداء
وقد نسميها سوداء ولكنها في
الواقع ليست سوداء حقيقية ، لكن هذا
أقرب إلى اللون الأسود الحقيقي من أي شيء آخر
على هذا الكوكب وهو يحدث ثورة في
كل شيء من الفضاء  استكشاف
الهندسة المعمارية من الصعب جدًا
فهم اللون الأسود الأكثر سوادًا في
العالم ، أعني أنك تسمع أنه من المنطقي
أنك تعتقد أنه يمكنك تصور ذلك ولكن
رؤيته شيء
مختلف جدًا جدًا لدرجة أنه يغير من
أبعاد كائن فهو ليس
اللون هو غياب اللون لذلك هذا
ما يحدث عندما لا يكون لديك ضوء
ينعكس على المشاهد
فلا ترى شيئًا لذلك يرسمه دماغك
باللون الأسود وقد يبدو مثل الطلاء
ولكنه في الواقع مكون من
أنابيب نانوية كربونية مجهرية تزرع في
المختبر  خارج لندن ،
إنه مصنوع من
أنابيب نانوية كربونية فردية وهذه الأنابيب النانوية الكربونية
تشبه شفرات العشب الطويلة جدًا
وتتخيل لو كنت تمشي بشريًا
حول في العشب يبلغ ارتفاعه ألف قدم ، ما مقدار
القليل من الأبيض الذي يمكن أن يصل إلى الأمر
من هذا القبيل ، ولكن على نطاق صغير
جدًا ، يشبه إلى حد كبير ثقبًا أسود
، فهذه مقارنة مثيرة للاهتمام لأن
هذه المادة تساعد العلماء على
التعمق في أعماق السماء أكثر من أي وقت مضى  قبل أن
يتصرف مثل غطاء العدسة
لكاميرا vantablack ، يمنع بشكل أساسي
توهج العدسة في التلسكوبات القوية ،
مما يقلل من هذا الضوء الشارد يسمح لنا
برؤية بعض الأشياء الخافتة
والبعيدة في الكون ، لذا
كلما اقتربنا من تحقيق
اللون الأسود المطلق ،  قادرون على
استكشاف السواد أعلاه ،
لكن الفضاء ليس هو
الفنانون الوحيدون المبتكرون والمصممين والموسيقيين الذين يريدون
وضع أيديهم على فانتابلاك.
الانقسام في الفضاء سيكون كما لو كنت
تنظر إلى السماء ليلا
وفي الواقع نحن نخلق نوعًا من
مجال النجوم معه إنه سواد
ستبدو مثل مجرة درب التبانة ولكنك سترى في
ضح النهار قد
ة مكافحة الأسود على جعلنا نف
ر أكثر في الضوء الذي نتمكن من الوصول إل
ه لديه القدرة على جعلنا ند
ك كم هو مورد ثمين  أنه